I don't think there's you can spend too
much time watching film die I think you
can spend too much time trying to
dissect every single thing I think
there's times where you're playing a
team that like them that they play
they're certain coverages and they play
them really well that you just have to
go out there and execute that's the
biggest thing the plays are gonna be
there you're gonna have chances in the
game to have opportunities but they're
not gonna be a ton so when you do that
those opportunities to make sure you
execute at a high level
patro homes talking to reporters on
Wednesday about watching film and
getting himself ready for the Super Bowl
last year in the aftermath of the 13 to
3 loss to the Patriots Rams coach Sean
McVeigh suggested that he over-prepared
he went back and watched too much and
maybe it got into his head and screwed
him up a little bit but you know teams
often go back two years in preparing for
a key game so I don't know that you can
over prepare Chris I think that you know
that extra little bit of time and I've
had this conversation with coaches
before like you know it's fascinating
that you can spend every waking moment
studying film from other teams and other
games and other this and other that for
ideas and eventually the response was
holy crap now I'm nervous I need to get
back to work
I mean that is a reality that that you
never know what that last play you look
at whether that's gonna be the one that
gives you the idea that makes all the
difference in the world at the right
time I mean the Patriots surely are
happy with their over preparation for
the Seahawks with the play that they
used at the goal line in Super Bowl xlix
I'm sure they were happy they were ready
for that one
right because they had gone back and
studied enough film so I don't think you
can't be over prepared for a Super Bowl
III don't know if you can be over
prepared either and listen I don't even
know if I buy what Sean McVeigh is
trying to sell us last year about over
preparing I watched that game on film it
was the same play as they ran all year
long okay so you know I don't know you
know you you you certainly I think this
is the big thing I look at right yeah
the first week you get your whole game
plan in everything's ready let's go
let's go play football you know the
second week you can just tinker oh you
know you know you're either the
pressures off because the game plan is
not there but you know just from friends
I've talked to and things yeah you just
continue to watch film and oh you know
that's a good idea maybe tomorrow
Wednesday of Super Bowl week even though
we have the game plan in I'll throw in
these five
four or five more new plays here just
because I like them and I think they
give us a chance so you know this week
of the Super Bowl because so much of the
preparation is already done
I do think you can fall into that trap
but I don't know if it's a bad trap I
don't think it is and here's the other
thing to me Mike that jumps out about
this matchup you know
mahomes Andy Reid they should have great
experience with this defense
the 49ers play the seattle scheme as
we've talked about right so many times
well they've played this defensive
scheme a lot over the last few years to
Sandy and that Los Angeles chargers this
is what they've run they've played them
four times they've played the Jaguars
each of the last two years they run the
scheme of course the seattle seahawks
run the scheme so they have and they
played them last year so i'm saying they
should have a good inventory of bass
plays or ways to attack right off the
bat from teams that they've played in
their own division and through the
league the last two years who were very
similar to what the the 49ers do Mike
and part of what Patrick mahomes has
done so far in preparing to face the
49ers he has watched film of ravens
hosting the 49ers one of San Francisco's
only losses this year Lamar Jackson the
things he was able to do against that
defense
here's mahomes explaining what he
learned from watching Lamar Jackson
versus San Francisco's D I know I can't
Juke like Lamar or do stuff like that
but I feel like I can't extend plays or
not when I watch similar opponents like
a watch with Lamar plan the 49ers isn't
seeing how he could extend plays then I
know that that's some stuff that I could
take away but I obviously can't run that
the the same agility or speed that he
can right but you don't have to be all
the way at the Lamar Jackson level to
still have the ability to extend the
plays to Juke guys to make guys miss to
avoid tacklers to run the ball and and
continue to be the leading rusher for
the Kansas City Chiefs in the 2019
postseason and Chris yesterday Peter
King and I were talking about this and I
know this is a theme that comes up from
time to time and some Chiefs fans are a
little bit upset with me yeah because I
suggested that as you've said in the
past when the quarterback chooses to run
the ball you got to make him pay yeah
sure not saying you got to take him out
I'm saying you got to apply a dirty hit
what I'm saying is yes fair game he's
fair game and you've got teams that err
on the side of staying away from a
quarterback near the sideline my point
yesterday is maybe they won't maybe
they're willing to risk a penalty if it
means reminding Patrick mahomes he
doesn't get to handtuch rules when he
decides to take off with the football he
gets the same rules a lot of running
backs yeah no I mean when running
becomes a big part or a theme of your
game as a quarterback defensive
coordinators are gonna start to preach
this hey they want him to run around hey
he wants to scramble you know we got to
make them pay and you're right it's not
about dirty play but I think that yes if
I'm the 49ers I tote the line of who
he's about to step out of bounds oh okay
I might hit him this time it's the first
quarter I'll take a 15-yard penalty
whatever it may be I'll risk it for just
laying a little you know laying the wood
on up to a degree let's be clear we're
not saying do it on purpose we're saying
let's shed this oh that we see we see
that demeanor sure how often from
defensive players when a quarterback to
decide oh he's a quarterback well if
it's a running back you hit him and if
the quarterback becomes the running back
it's the same rules and I imagine that
Robert Sala and all the position coaches
on the 49ers defensive staff is showing
the film and that 27-yard touchdown
Chris and telling the guys we better not
do this against the chief so we have no
chance yeah no no I mean his running has
gone to another level his movements gone
to another level this is gonna be the
key to the game this is what Robert Shaw
is gonna be just preaching to his
defensive line for the next two weeks we
got to get after him it's got to be you
for I don't want to be blitzing this guy
you got to be rabid dogs we can't let
him out of the pocket all of those
things mahomes got into a new level is
scrambling so this will be big part of
the game
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports